非常感谢义东和替上龙的一个邀请然后今天的话也是主要是给大家分享一下就是这些整体的一个跨单整体的引进到现在的一个历程OK那么其实我们先跨断这个概念的话其实整体上说也是在Ranitube其实当时的一个诞生之后其实是有了一个广泛的一个踢击的对那么一般来说我们其实
呃对于矿端这个场景说的话那么其实我们就可以把它理解为这范旨就是不同操作系导提供一个UI的一个顺框架那么呃业务同学通过一套弹码去做呃通过一些中间层的一个抹拼然后拼臂诶诶诶诶诶诶诶诶诶诶诶诶诶现在没有成音了吧对
然后模拼掉整体的一个CPU和GPU的差异然后去完成相应的这样的一个试图训论那么其实真相来说就是划断的话它其实真相就是面向的是不同的操作系统不同的一个平台那么其实最初的时候那么在比如说18.0的手当时抖音其实最早的时候也是开始引入一些划断那个方案对那么当时的话其实是有一些web的一些方案对那么
但是其实在对于一些特定的一些业务场景来说的话那么其实就会遇到一些问题那么其实就比如说包括就是外部整体的一个家载它会有一个比较长的一些白屏号式对那么以及相应的一些那个叫端的那些方法它可能会有一个比较长的这样的一些损耗对那么其实对当时的一些场景来看的话那么其实就可以看到当年比如说19年的一些瞬间活动的
那么其实就会造成一个问题那么呃就是加载的耗时特别长那么他展现的话会有一个呃楼顶的这样一个状态的那么其实对于一些你需要一些非常极致铁内场起来说的话那么其实就会产生一些呃用户的这样一些流失的那么用户可能会觉得呃我在这边摆平了很久对那么没有进到当前的页面那么我就不一定要继续往下走那么可能就直接去退出等因为这可能说
当前页面也不一定是他一定想要去进入的这样子的话其实对于当前页面的一个伸头额转化的来说的话其实就会变得非常的差那么隐疾的话就是也有一些就是一些功能的一些定制吧对那么比如说就是一些外部场景可能说不不满足的一些功能那么其实也是需要去定制的那么其实我们这边可以看到整体的演绎历程的话我们可能说主要是中方为降级的阶段嘛就是刚才说的
那么接下来的话,那么其实在万步不满足到这样的情况下的话,其实当时我们也是去引入了原类地位这样的一个方案。那么原类地位它有一个好处的话,其实那么它其实能够在相应的这样一些定值功能的场景下,那么它其实可以做到一些更好的这样一些业务的一些自定义,对。
就是比如说某个搜索业务或者说一些电厂商机业务他想选一些他计定一些功能卡片或者一些比如说像彩蛋类的或者说一些倒计时双十一类别的像有这样的功能的话他可以通过那头同学的这样的一些提前的这样的一些代码的这样的一些买入对那么可以将这些定制的一些功能去得到相应的这样的一个满足提供给业务场景去做到一个使用对
那么但是其实这也是今天的一个阶段吧因为当时其实19年的时候啊董音也是和就是老罗那边当时有了一个签约队那其实也是当时啊自己在电商场景下的一个就是发展的一个起步吧对那么其实当时啊对于一些就是电商的一些核心场景那么也其实是由哪条去迁移到了
对那么去做一个展现对这些也是包括当时的一些电商的一些详情阶队然后以及一些电商的一些体单场景对那么这部分页面其实呃建议到APO之后当时也是有了一个比较大的一个问题呃建议到Renovative之后也是有一个比较大的一个问题对那么就是呃相应来说就是会发现就是业务策做了一个做了一些APO的一些数据数据的一些那个实验对然后也是发现呃
进到相关页面的这样的一个耗时那么它其实是有增加的以及的话就是对于整体的业务的这样的一些数据包括电商的一些核心数据包括GNV等一些数据那它其实是存在一些烈化的这样的一些表现的对那么其实这样子的话也是趋势的其实原来这个其实并不能够满足业务的一些完全的这样的诉求对那么因为它
对于公司人类的营收它产生了影响对那么也是当时也是在这样的一个毕竟之下的话也是我们其实是呃去有了诞生了就是我们内部的这样的一个另一个方案对那么呃对那么同其实同期的话就是呃也是呃flutter其实也是在一个就是逐步的这样的一个演技类过程中对不过其实由于就是等于整体当时对于宝达角的一个管控吧对那么其实flutter其实也一直没有在
抖音等就是比较大了这样的一些app上去做一个机乘对但其实flutter其实对于一些独立的一些app那么他其实也是有他非常不到的一些场景的对那么再回到面临的一些问题吧对那么其实说到就是relative然后以及我们在做一个就是links的方案的话那么其实他对于人效来说的话那么他其实是可以解决一些lative场景就是双端的这样一个人效问题对
那么不过的话可能说是要去做提前的一些就是基础技术的将一些建设在端策对需要哪一个端策同学将一些基础一些端组建断的孽然后一些端方法去做这样的一个建设武器对那么在相应的一个基础孽比较完备的像那个状态下的话其实研发人效其实是有很大的一些提升的对那么再往后的话其实因为其实
就于前端同学说的话那么他其实他们可能说更喜欢更习习惯于去做一些呃就是用HTML去做一些构计或者说就是follow一些呃弹路三C的这样一些标准的那么其实我们也是有就是呃满足的三个人家那个诉求也是有一个PIA的这样的一个能力对那么可以保证就是呃前同学继续写的还是呃H5的那么也是在外面上去做一些承载
那么我们去通过一些方式去将其的这样的一个展现去做到一个尽可能的一个提升那么可能说就可以满足一些权力场景的一些诉求那么其实经历了比较长的这样的一部分的这样的一个时间变革的话那么其实夸展技术对公司内各业务与各团队那么它其实也是有着很大的一些影响那么其实
比较明显的一点的话其实就是在于一个业务的一个形态吧对那么其实最初的时候包括我们也说到就是电商的相关页面或者说这边呃上面屏幕上所展示的一个缩索的一个页面吧对那么他其实呃基本上也先其实都是由课文同学去做相应的一个业务的一个维护的对那么呃但是他可能说拥抱的就是跨平台方案之后的话那么就可能说会产生这样的一种变化对
那么整后端同学的一样的职责就会产生一个变化那么更多的去做一些支撑的一些工作那么业务形态的话也是变得是由扣端同学更多的去做业务支撑然后变得去做基础能力支撑对那么业务更多的是由前端同学去做这样的一个承载那么同时的话这部分其实对于产品来说也是可以更好地去满足一些PM相关的一些就是快速迭代的这样的一些诉求
对 那么对于其实搜索页面而言那么最初其实是native的一个页面那么中间其实是在2019年的时候是有网就是Renative做了一次签页那么当时的话其实数据的话是有一定的降低一个所耗的那么对于一些就是没有去成功加载Renative的页面的话当时也是做了一个web的一个dody
再往后的话其实我们也是为了去弥补到就是这部分对于业务的一个锁号对那么当时搜索这个场景是迁移到Links之后那么它的业务数据的话其实是很lative的业务数据是一个打平的一个状态对那么还有的一个比较大的一个就是业务形态的一个影响的话对那么其实就是公司的很多一些重要的一些活动对那么其实都会选择去用links去做一个业面的这样的一个构建对
那么其实就以土壮为例那么第一页面其实就是日常的一些春节活动的一个页面的那么这样的一些活动页面那么它会有非常多一些玩法那么一般来说现在都是由Linkz去做一个页面的一个承载也是可以满足到整体的一个页面的一个性能那么又可以保证就是一些就是PM测的一些就是紧急需求的一些分版
那么第二个的话其实也是世界杯的一个页面对那么其实包括就因为最近其实也是也是世界杯的整体的一个就是阶段吧对那么其实大家也是不知道大家有没有就是用我的页面对那么其实上抖音然后会有一个世界杯的一个tab对那么其实点开来之后的话其实就是我们的这样的一个世界杯的这样的一个就是落地业吧分体业吧对那么其实整体上的一个存在的话也是有links去做一个存在然后
相关的一个研发同学的话其实是由几部分组成吧对那么其实由就是扣端同学去做一个基底对那么上层业务的话其实是由就是前来同学去就是进行相应的这样的一个构建对这样其实有一个好处的话就是业务就是业务同学可以就快速的去迭代相应的这样一个场景对
以及之前的一些就是新冠肺炎相关的一些就是整体也对那么其实那些也是比较早那些是20年初当时令死我们就是刚起步的一个时间去做的一个页面对就会比较快的去满足到就相应的比较紧急的这样的一些就是场景的这样的一些长线诉求对避免一些就是发板的一些来不及
对那么其实从团队过场也刚才也说到那么其实对业务和团队就是业务策的这样的一个人员来说那么其实是有会有一个冲击的对那么就是可能说很多客户的同学那么这时候他们其实就会有一些就是疑问可能说他们业务其实就会由前端去做成接了那么他们可能说职责就可能会比较模糊嘛但其实
其实也并不是这样子的那么因为他们其实可以通过sign的一些基础能力的建设对那么其实也是之前所提到的就是中间的加那个定制功能因为有非常多的一些功能其实是可能说是业务策也有的或者说是就是比较哪一个特殊的一些功能的话对那么这部分其实是有那个端色东西去做一个基础建设这样会对于整体的一个业务策的一个价格来说会非常网固的
然后包括就是相应的减蓝同学他就专职在就是相应的业务的一个处理然后当地同学就专职在整体的一个技术架构能力的一个处理建设上那么其实从这个点的话其实就会引传出来一个问题对那么就是啊化碳技术整理的架构分层那么应该去如何去分分层子以及如何去许设计的那么这边
其实整体上我这边初步列了一下大概就这么几层嘛对那么最上面一层的话其实就DSL层那么这层的话其实更多的面向的是就是业务业务的开发同学就是业务逻辑的开发同学那么可能说目前来看就是主要是前端同学那么比较多的可能说就是像前端一些比较熟悉使用一些就算包括像Reapt像View这样子对那么
中间层的话它会有两个层片上面这层的话其实是一个断能力层那也是我刚刚说到的业务策而且可以去做的很多的一些事情对这里面就包括了一些业务能的一些定制对然后包括一些业务策的一些预加载处理或者一些缓矩处理对那么也不限于不限于这些的一些业务策的一个优化对那么以及嗯偏下一点的就是一些bridge断能力然后或者说资源的一些处理或者一些监控的处理对
那这几个部分的话它可以说是作为一个就是通用的一个基础的面对那么整体上这一层端的一层那么其实我们对它的一个定义的话其实是可插拔对那么对于不同的场景不同的速度来说的话它都可以做到一个任意插拔任意去定制对那么以满足说不同f不同环境的让那些差异性对对那么再往下的话其实就是渲染行程对那在这里面的话我们会去做一些
就是具体上的一个包括我们这里面会包括两个就是Rounder比众我们的VM就是虚拟阶然后以及就是Render Engine在这边去做一些就是业务逻辑的这样的一个解析和执行队然后以及是最终去将相应的一个指令去发送到就是端的一个渲染层对那么最底下也是我们端的渲染层那么就是目前来看的话也就是RS和Android的两层对那么
分别在两个不同的平台层上去做相应的这样的一个渲染的这样的一个会智那么其实这层鞋非常关键的等于其实对于iOS和Android来说的话那么它在平台层的整体的差异性其实还是非常大的包括平台组建的一个渲染然后以及整体的一个渲染管线上来说的话它其实都是有比较大的一些差异性的然后在这边我们需要去做很多的一些就是
相当于一个抹平的这样的工作吧对就是以保证就是经过到我们中间训论论已经之后那么从上层业务策所写在码那么将它做那个统一的这样一个训论之内然后发送到GPU去做最终的这样一个训论那么对那么其实对于端同学说的话那么其实这会有几个考虑点嘛对那么需要去关注一些点那么其实第一点的话其实也是比较重要的
那么就是业务自定义的年那么这时候可能说需要去做很多的一些就是双端的这样的一个差异性的一个抹平对那么因为毕竟iOS和Android整体上系统上差异性很大然后相应的这样的一个执行顺旋包括Layout逻辑它其实都是有非常多的一些差异性在这里面的然后包括其实业务策等于自定义组织它可能本身在业务逻辑上它本身也可能存在一些差异对
所以说这层的一个差异的话是需要去做到一个抹平对怎么样第二点的话其实呃就是呃就业务测其实更多的呃可能说需要更多的一些大前端这样一些同学对那么因为其实对于前端同学来说的话就是他们以往来说他们呃写代码的话其实就基本上嗯从来没有关注过性能和稳定性的对
对但是呃当他们就是其实直接通过跨跨平台的这样的方案其实对他们而言他们是直接就去做了端会制这样的一些工作对所以说在这样的一个背景下的话那么其实对于呃钱中学来说对于客户大人来说那么其实两方其实都是需要去做一些拓展的一个随机的对那么因此的话其实更更加就是状态的可能就是说是一个融合吧对就是钱中学可以
呃去更多的去了解到就是一些内存的一些分配对于以及对于一些CPU的讲的一些消耗对呃以避免自己写的代码其实实际上造成了比如说呃F的一个过高的一个那个CPU占用或者说过高的内存内存的两个占用造成一些稳定性呃问题的这样一些哪个触发对那么对于端色同学来说的话也是有可能说不局限于就是端侧的一些技术能力然后更多的也可以去参与到前端的这样的一些
就是業務如計的這樣的一些構建上這樣子的話其實就可以更好地去理解到就是兩側它其實各自不同的這樣的一個側重點那麼其實做到一個融合之後那麼其實就可以更好地去避免到最終潛在的一些問題的一個發生那麼接下來的話其實就講一講就是就是誇張技術其實目前的一些瓶頸與挑戰
那么其实谈到就是跨平台一个瓶颈的话其实大家应该日常也都会有一些讨论对那么其实包括从业界的跨平台方案发展的哦现在再来说的话那么其实经过很多的阶段包括当年的一些以上reality然后以及像wix像flutter对那么发展到现在那么其实今天这么长时间那么其实跨跨平台
这个领域来说遇到的一些挑战是非常多的,包括遇到的一些事也是非常多的,对。那么首先我觉得这张来点的话呢,就是一个DSL的一个标准不一的一个问题,对。那么首先要考虑的点的话,就是快遍来面向的就是受众是来一方同学的,那么可能说是从像从儿人来说的话,那么其实儿人他整体的一个DSL,那么他其实就是基于自家的react。
那么他的受众很明确就是前端对但他其实又对你就是端能力就是一些自定义组件然后包括会自定一些通信来说他又是有一些要求在这的对所以说而人的话也是呃我理解为他其实目的上也是为了一个就是融合的这样一个方案对那么说然后以及说像那个呃像wix的话其实就是view然后以及flutter的话那flutter其实是一个呃
反而至今的话其实没有最终推广开我觉得一个很大的原因的话就是因为他并没有拥抱到任何一个社区对那么其实他并不符合很多大部分的开发者的一个习惯对那么呃就是就是使用小flutter的可能说呃这个跨平台发的人同学的话可能要去学习dart要学习呃很多的一些东西对那么对于就是eo的将那些开发者来说他的一个成本架构他不太
符合到就是以往的跨平台领域的基本群体的基础能力对所以说以及它整理的维护来说的话它要去建立一个比较大的一个社区对以及生态的话其实也是需要去做一个二次建设的对所以说我理解就是从业绩来说那么这样的一个比较好的一个跨平台的这样的一个方案的话需要去
呃做到一个很好的这样的一个拥抱拥抱社区的这样的一个点对那么跨平台还有个点的话其实就是呃双端的不一致对那么双端不一致其实是呃一个呃我理解其实是一个基础的一个问题吧对因为从跨平台来说它本身就是要跨的就是多端的这样的一些能力不一致那么目前来说可能说是像iOS和enjoy那么在未来的话如果说有其他的一些呃
就是平台的话那其实这样的话又会多一个端对那么其实这每一个端的一些那个差一点的话其实都是需要去做一个抹平的对那么其实对于像跨平台人员每做每多一个端那么他就要多做一次这样的一个兼容的话那其实成本就是会非常的高对那么这也是主要的一个瓶颈点嘛对以及就是对于开发者以及对于底层回护者来说他其实都是一个很大的一个呃成本在这边对
那么还有个点的话就是呃我认为这是一个端策的有算力不不足对那么因为其实画平台目前来说其实基本上都是通过一套呃比如说对于一个Ui的一个描述去做下发然后再端策解析然后去做Ui的一个会许对那么这部分来说的话那从目前像也有的像然后像发达一样对那么其实呃
都需要有端测的一些很多的一些那一个计算在这边对那么其实会很影响一些性能所以说在一些低端机场景的话那么其实都会有很大的一些性能瓶颈对那么上面那个双端不予是这边再补充一点那么其实这点来说发达值做的是挺好的对那么它其实它的思路的话是在底从自己去接管一个圈它不走就是那个端平台测的一个引擎圈对那么它这样的话其实可以保
就是一定程度上的去保证它在虽然层面的一致但是它也是有更多的一些其他的不一致的点那么其实也都是需要去做到一个就是尽力的这样一个模型的对那么接下来说就是嗯那么就是瓶颈在这边对那么我们这样应该如何去可能说去看就跨平台未来如何去突破这个瓶颈对那么其实这边主要几个点
等我的理解来看的话其实主要这几个点的那首先就是必须要就是呃要去满足到开发者的一个习惯对因为你画平台整理的一个方案的话那么必然是由哪个开发的同学去评判就是是否呃是否是一个比较好的这样的一个方案对然后以及的话就是呃比如说在整体的这样的方案方案当中来说目前主要是就是前端侧的这样的一个DSL是一个主力的这样的一个方向对
那么这样子的话,其实就需要去严格的去遵循到一个标准,那么就前端测了一个大度3C的一个标准,那么其实呃呃,快平台方案就是包括RN,包括我们自己在做的Minks,对,然后其实我们也一直都在尽力的去做到一个标准的一个遵循,对,但其实呃,也是由于就双端的一些呃,就端,端测能力的一些不一致,或者旋旋
那你有一些不一致那么其实这部分标准也并没有被完全的这样一个满足的但是其实从跨平台整体的一个角度来看的话那么这个点其实是一个非常非常高的那个点那么其实我理解其实大家如果在做跨平台的时候其实也需要非常去关注到一个标准的这样一个遵循那么还有点的话就是要拥抱社区对那么建设生态
那么其实开发者是最重要的这样一个群体对那么不可能说就是做跨平台方案的东西就把所有的整体的一个就是方案做到一个全体对那必然的话其实需要去建设一个社区那么通过这个社区去不断的对这个方案去做一个反捕对那么包括像RN包括现在呃对我们内部的一些方案也是了其实我们呃其实也都是说我们尽力的去
通过开发者的一些网络通过生态的一些共建能让我们整体的一个流程它可以说是一个尽可能说是往就是一个更好的更合理的方向去发展然后也是就是通过大家的一个建设去将整体的一个方案的话去做到一个更好的这样的一个输出对那么这边也说一下就是法特的一个思作话其实刚刚我也说到就是一个很好的一个点他在就是多担不一致的这样的一参临下
那么因为现在来说我们在做跨平台那么跨的是OS和Android那么到未来如果说车上就是一些比如说VR场景比如说一些像眼镜场景或者一些就是在往后的一些就是其他的一些交互场景对那必然的其实是需要有一个展示界面的这样一个存在的对那么这样一个展示界面的话那么其实它可能说
你对我们而言 那么就是需要去对它做一个渲染指令的发送那么如果说我们在中间的层那么避免到使用到端侧的渲染能力那么直接去等过一个原来人群直接去对接到GPU那么这样的话可能说我们对于相应的一些场景来说的话就可以做到一个更好的以致性的建设
也是其实也是尽可能去建设一致性的因为不可能有都是完完全全的一致性的但是我们我理解其实对于跨平台长期发展的话那可能说网资讯上的方向去走我觉得是一个比较不错的一个思路的以及可以满足到一定的将来一个在确认层面的一个那个一致性对对那么加来还是算力对那么其实算力目前来说就是也有很多一些问题那么就是包括
现在像那个端平台层然后和相应的这样那个树立树立层那么当中会有非常多一些数据这样的一个传输不通对那么其实像R的话其实之前被人诟兵的很多的一些白兵或者滑动中的卡顿其实也都是由于这个算力的一个问题导致的对以及的话就是嗯对于一些嗯高端起来说那么其实它是有多核心的对但其实目前你看呃对于多核能力的使用也目前来说
各跨边方也是完全不足对那其实对于突破这个频率买说的话也是可以去更多的去考虑说如何将多合的一些人一区送起来那么对于整体的现成架构的这样一个设计调整那么去可以去做到一个更好的一个思考吧对那么嗯 接下来的话就讲一下就是关于日本制和一个未来的一个趋势吧对那么其实刚才我也讲到那么其实我们
从本质上来看的话跨别来一个本质其实就是通过同一套摄像引擎去在多中端去实现业务的一个展现对那么这个多中端的来说其实刚才说我们不用那么局限那么我们可以说目前是在移动端那么它可以跨到Mac端可以跨到Pc端因为凡是做那个摄像程的那么它其实都是可以去做这样的一个拓展的对就是VL成本
对那么对于未来的一个多平台的这样的一个呃就是可能说涉及到的一个同步来说的话那么这一方面来说可能说是靠着呃像一些嗯像例如像苹果像那个像安卓他们可以去往多多终端去做制定一些标准的那么这是一方面可以去做一个拓展的一个点的另外一个点的话就是我刚说到的可能说我们可以借助一些呃那个
然后可以将就是多中端来说都直接对接到那个GPU去做相关的一个会智之类那这样子来说那么多平台它可以是完全一致的让你一个展现的一个效果大家点的话就是发送对那么其实上一期的一个讲师其实也是主要的去做了一些发送的一些就是介绍的大家也可以去回顾一下那么其实这个的话其实
目前也说是在前段界比较新颖的思路其实也是大家可以考虑看看WhatsApp如何去因为它整体上性能的话相对于普通的一些事情的话它可以更好它整体上执行效率是更好的在有限的算力下的话它其实可以带来更好的性能的一个体验对那么最后的话其实是对于整体快平台的一点建议
那么其实今天做了这些点的话那么其实第一点建议来说的话就是对于上次的DSL来说的话那么就是可以说对于不同的不同场景来说它可以是不一致的它可以是一个多种形化的对那么必须要拥抱到不同的这样的一个开发者群体对那么比如说那么用像react叫做的一个群体的话他们可以就是
呃去拥抱react去做相应的降临构景对那么拥抱view那么他们可以去选view对那么以及若说通过写其他一些script那么他们也可以去使用对那么这样的话呃降了一个多中心化的一个DSL的话那么通过中间层去做到一个磨平对这样子的话可以避免开发者去被DSL所前置对这样子来说的话就是呃跨平来方来说可能可以被接受的接受度可以更高的
那么第二点的话就是对于跨度容量场景可以在不同站立的基础上做兼容对那么对接到端旋转或者说自旋那么去实现一个就是在就是不同场景下的这样的一个不同的一个适配那么最后一点的话就是啊旋转基础的旋转指定的一个标准化对那么可以就保证将那一套标准化的一个旋转指定可以在目前的这样的一些端旋转场景下
或者说再往后走的话走到就是其他的渲染方案上来说的话可以保证它其实是一套渲染指定标准它可以实现一个快速的一个前移和对齐然后以及保证整体上在多中端渲染的一个一致性那么整体上的话是我今天以上的一个分享对那么下面时间交换给周成Ok那个
稍等一下我刚才发现那个直播间有一些朋友在问一些问题啊第一个就是说我们呃刚才有同学问就是为什么不直接用flutter这个我觉得必要可以大概回答一下这个问题吗ok那我先回答一下这个问题为什么不直接用flutter呢呃其实刚才我在分享中也就是稍微提了一些点对就是首先
它有一个基础包大小的这样的一个影响的那么它对于一些很成熟的这样一些大型工程来说比如像抖音像TikTok这样头条来说那么它整体的包一下对于速度来说是一个非常大的一个成本对那么机身进来之后会影响整体速度的一个各项核心指标对
这是最主要一点给第二点的话说的话那么对于主要的一个业务购建同学来说那么他的一个上手成本还是比较高的那么想大了他的话那前两同学一扣挡水多少去进行了解然后要去搭各种的一个那个端策的一些基础的经验那么这必然会带来一个非常大的一个以及非常长的这样的一个时间那个成本嗯明白所以主要还是说第一个是关于包大小第二个是关于那个
因为是他全新的DSL嘛对吧所以可能会有一定的学习成本学习成本以及就是基础的一些工程化的一些组件各方面的其实都是一些成本OK我理解这个其实应该是针对一些这应该是大公司的问题对不对如果是一些小型团队应该就没有这样的负担了对不对对是的然后其实我刚才说了其实
法特的话那个在公司内的很多的一些就是独立App上来说也是非常好用的对因为小App的话他没有那么大的一个报道小的负担啊他不需要就是去承担一些因为报道小增长带来的一些其他的一些所好的影响所以说而且就是小独立团队他们去做一个法特方向的一个构建来说那么他沟通也是比较快的那么不会产生那个多团队的一个沟通问题所以说
它在字节内部来说就是在独立小速度上用的也都是非常多非常好的所以其实我们在这些独立的小的这种类似探索型业务里面其实用的还是挺多的是吧对它可以去快速的构建一个双端基本上一致的这样的一些业务逻辑对然后可以保证一个探索型的业务快速的去得到一个有效的一个业务验证嗯ok
好的,因為我看也有同學在問有沒有對比過Flood和Mix因為這個我們剛剛應該Beal已經在他前面的內容中已經講過了然後如果感興趣的話可以後面看我們的路播